شكرا لك ميسون وهذه ساعه اخباريه من تغطيه
العربيه لتداعيات الازمه في السودان
طيران الجيش السوداني يستهدف ما وقع قوات
الدعم السريع بمحيط مطار الخرطوم والاخيره
ترد بالمضادات
لكم انه عندما تنجلي هذه الازمه قريبا
مبعوث البرهان يعلن جاهزيه الجيش للدخول
بعمليه سياسيه شامله ويتعهد بعدم اقصاء اي
كيان
واستمرارا لعمليه الاجلاء عبر بورسودان
سفينه سعوديه تصل من الاجداء على متنها
رعايا اغلبهم امريكيون
ومن اخبارنا الدوليه ايضا
تزامنا مع هجوم اوكرانيا مضاده الدفاع
الروسيه تعلن اتخاذها خطوات لتسريع انتاج
الاسلحه
لازم اشتغل يعني في في الظروف لازم اشتغل
السلع ذاته في زياده واي حاجه زايد لازم
انا اشتغل
البلد ما امنه
بقى صعب
طبعا ما بيعرف ينرفيه ولا قلت
خاطر بنفسه يحاول يشتغل القواد ما حبابه
والخوف ما منه فايده
على واقعي اصوات الانفجارات والاسلحه
الثقيله واختراقات هنا وهناك اعلنت خارجيه
جنوب السودان عن ان البرهان وحميدتي وافق
مبدئيا على هدنه لمده سبعه ايام تبدا في
الرابع من مايو الجاري على الارض
للشبكاتهم ما زالت مستمره بين الجيش
والدعم السريع تتركز في العاصمه الخرطوم
بمدنها الثلاث فيما شنت طائرات الجيش
غارات جويه على نقاط الدعم السريع في عده
مناطق وردت الاخيره بمضادات الطيران فيما
باتت الاوضاع الطبيه في تفاقم مستمر حيث
خرجت عشرات المستشفيات عن الخدمه فيما
باتت المخازن الطبيه فارغه في بعض
الولايات
[موسيقى]
ونتوقف امام التفاصيل ما اعلنته خارجيه
جنوب السودان حول المبادره الجديده اكدت
ان رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني قائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقنه وافق من حيث
المبدا على هدنه لمده سبعه ايام تبدا يوم
الخميس المقبل وزرت خارجيه جنوب السودان
قالت في بيان لها ان البرهان ودبلو وافق
ايضا خلال هذا الاتصال الهاتفي مع رئيس
جنوب السودان سيلفاكير على تسميه ممثلين
عنهما للمشاركه في محادثات سلام تعقد في
مكان ما يتم اختياره
وفي ذات السياق قال السفير دفع الله الحاج
علي المبعوث الخاص لرئيس مجلس السياده
السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان قال انه
سيتم ترتيب عمليه سياسيه شامله بالسودان
بعد نهايه الازمه اضاف السفير ان الهدنه
الحاليه في السودان انسانيه ولا اتفاق او
مفاوضات مع الدعم السريع كما قال دفع الله
الحاج علي ان الجيش السوداني لن يقبل باي
حلول تفرض عليه كما اكد مبعوث البرهان
توجيه دعوه الى الجامعه العربيه والاتحاد
الافريقي للاعب دور في ازمه السودان
اؤكد لكم انه عندما تنجلي هذه الازمه
قريبا
وتتحقق وتسيطر الشرعيه في البلاد
سيكون الامر
خلافه ما كان عليه بمعنى ان يتم
الدخول
وترتيب عمليه سياسيه واسعه شامله
لا يتم فيها اقصاء اي من الكائنات
السياسيه السودانيه الا ما سبق ان اتفق
عليه السودانيين للتمهيد
للانتقال الديمقراطي الحر
وعن وقف اطلاق النار قال السفير دفع الله
الحاج مبعوث رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
ان الجيش السوداني يتعاطى مع الهدنه على
اساس انها هدنه انسانيه نافيا ان يكون
هناك اي تفاوض مع قوات الدعم السريع حتى
الان
مفهومنا الان فيما يتعلق بالهدنه هي هدنه
انسانيه
ليست هنالك ليس هنالك حديث عن
اي اتفاق ولا تفاوض مباشر مع المليشيا
المتمرده نعم اقول لك نحن
سندعو
الجامعه العربيه
والاتحاد الافريقي
للاطلاع بدور فيما يتعلق بهذه الهدنه
والدول التي بادرت بها وهي المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
ونامل ان يكون للجامعه العربيه ثغلا ووزنا
وخاصه ان الاخ الامين العام للجامعه
العربيه قد عبر عن مشاعر
مؤيده للشرعيه في السودان منذ اليوم الاول
في هذا الاثناء وانا اتحدث معكم صدر قرار
من الجامعه العربيه
نص القرار على
التاكيد على الشرعيه في السودان وهي شرعيه
القوات المسلحه كمؤسسه وطنيه مسؤوله من
حمايه امن واستقرار السودان
القرار نصه ايضا على وطالب باخلاء قوات
الدعم السريع للمستشفيات التي تحتلها وعدم
الارتكاز فيها وعدم
اتخاذ العاملين في المجال الطبي دروعا
بشريه
هذا واعلن السفير احمد ابو زيد المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه المصريه للعربيه ان هناك
اقتراحا لتشكيل لجنه لمراقبه وقف اطلاق
النار في السودان وذلك ضمن اجتماع للاتحاد
الافريقي بحضور مصر
يعني هذا الامر مطروح للحوار في اطار في
اوطر عديده الحقيقه في اطار الاتحاد
الافريقي هناك اجتماع يعقد في الجامعه
العربيه نعلم ان جامعه الدول العربيه
اصدرت قرارا لليوم على مستوى المندوبين
الدائمين وهذا القرار تقدمت به مصر في
الحقيقه صدر اليوم منذ قليل ايضا مره اخرى
بيدعو الى وقف اطلاق النار
ويتناول مسائل عديده من ضمنها اهميه تثبيت
وقف اطلاق النار ويدعو ايضا المجتمع
الدولي لتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه للشعب
السوداني ودعم الدول كوار السودان التي
تتلقى او تستقبل المواطنين السودانيين عبر
الحدود
ولمتابعه جهود الاجلاء ايضا ينضم الينا من
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده مراسل
العربيه سلطان السلمي مرحبا
بك ضعنا في التفاصيل الخاصه بنقل الرعايه
الامريكيين التي تتم على متن السفينه حيث
نتابع هذه الصور الان معك مباشره سفينه
الملك الرياض
اهلا بكم اهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه العربيه
نتواجد حاليا على متن سفينه جلاله الملك
الرياض وهي الرحله الخامسه عشر منذ بدا
عمليات الاجلال من ميناء بورد سودان الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحري سوف ناخذكم في
جوله خاصه لشاشه العربيه كما نشاهد الان
بدات عمليات الانزال بعد ان وصلت هذه
السفينه من ميناء بورت سودان في رحله
استغرقت قرابه العشره الساعات من ميناء
بورد سودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده على متن هذه السفينه 220 راكبا من
خمسه جنسيات
نتحدث عن 91 من الجنسيه الامريكيه و14
مواطن السعودي وثلاثه كنديين واثنان من
جنوب السودان وواحد من الجنسيه السودانيه
ايضا نتحدث انه اعداد كبيره تصل الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده منذ بدء عمليات
الاجلاء خلال الماضيه نتحدث عن ارقام
اجماليه تتجاوز الخمسه الاف
مواطن اجنبي من مئه جنسيه تم اجلائهم من
ميناء بورسودان الى جده عبر قاعه الملك
فيصل البحريه او حتى الى قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه وكذلك الى ميناء جده الاسلامي
اعداد كبيره من الرعايه يتوافدون يوما بعد
يوم وتزداد الاعداد بشكل ملحوظ مع عمليه
مع كل عمليات اجلاء ايضا المتوقع وصول
سفينه مدنيه تجاريه سعوديه على متنها
اعداد تلامس الفين شخص يوم
ظهر يوم غد الان بدات عمليات الانزال
لهؤلاء الرعايه كما ذكرنا اعداد من
الرعايه بداوا بعمليات النزول نتحدث عن
اوائل واطفال وكبار السن بمختلف الجنسيات
والاعمار يتم التعامل معهم وفقاء مستوى
واحد نتحدث انه في متعلق بعمليات الاجلاء
المستمر من قبل السلطات السعوديه لهاؤلاء
الرعايه وسط حمايه
وعبر السفن القوات البحريه السعوديه من
ميناء بورت سوداني لقاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه يتواجد القنصل الامريكي على ارض
قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه لاستقبال الرعايه
وكذلك وجود عدد من السفراء وايضا من
القناص لاستقبال
لمده شهر واحد من قبل المديريه العامه
للجوازات نظرا لظرف الانساني الذي يعيش
هؤلاء
الصوت يتقطع قليلا سلطان
نعم اذا هذه مباشره من قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه في جده حيث مراسل عربيه سلطان
السلمي ينقل لكم الصوره وهناك رعايه كما
تشاهدون ينزلون من على متن السفينه الملك
الرياض
قادمين الى جده تمهيدا لنقلهم الى بلادهم
في اطار جهود تبذلها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لاجلاء الرعايه من السودان هل
يسمعني سلطان الانف بشكل احسن سلطان
نعم نعم كما نشاهد بدات عمليات الانزال
تتم عمليات الانزال بدءا باصحاب الحالات
الصحيه الطارئه الذي سوف تتعامل معهم
مركبات الاسعاف ويتم اجلاؤهم مباشره الى
اقرب مستشفى للتعامل مع هذه الحالات ومن
ثم النساء وكبار السن بعد ذلك بقيه الركاب
من الملفت وجود عدد من الاطفال على هذه
السفينه بشكل كبير جدا عكس خلاف او خلاف
السفن الاجلاء التي وصلت الى مقات الملك
فيصل البحريه خلال الايام الماضيه الان
كما نشاهد مركبه الاسعاف متواجده عدد من
قيادات الامنيه من الضباط السعوديين ويتم
استقبالهم او التاكد من ثلاثه انزالهم من
هذه السفينه يتم استقبالها
كبيره كما نشاهد على الشاشه هل هناك
احصائيه بالعدد الاجمالي الذي قدم على متن
هذه السفينه
نعم كما ذكرنا قبل قليل العدد يصل 220
راكبا من خمسه جنسيات من ضمنهم 91 من
الجنسيه الامريكيه واربعه عشر مواطن سعودي
وثلاثه كنديين واثناء من جنوب السودان
وواحد من الجنسيه اليمنيه وكذلك
109 افراد من الجنسيه السودانيه ممن تم
اجلائهم من ميناء بورت سوداني لقاعده
الملك فيصل البحري
الاجمالي لهؤلاء الرعايه منذ بدا عمليات
الاجلاء السعوديه
تجاوز الرقم الى 5000
مواطن اجنبي من مئه جنسيه اجنبيه
التعامل الى ان عدد ما تم تجاوز بالفعل
5000 ومن
102 من الجنسيات المختلفه
بالفعل ارقام تتزايد والجنسيات كذلك تزداد
وتختلف يوما عن يوم ايضا متوقع وصول سفينه
عسكريه سعوديه صباح يوم غد على متنها عدد
من الرعايه باختلاف الجنسياتهم ايضا كما
اشار السفير السعودي في الخرطوم طلبات
الاجلاء من قبل حكومات الاجنبيه تصل بشكل
كبير جدا الى السفاره السعوديه بعد
التنسيق مع وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه يتم
قبول عدد كبير منها والتعامل معها بحسب
الحقيه والاهميه والحاله الصحيه لهؤلاء
الرعايه ومن ثم يتم اجلائهم الى مدينه جده
ان كان الى قاعه الملك عبد الله الجويه او
حتى لا عبر قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه او
حتى الى ميناء جده الاسلامي وايضا خلال
يومين الماضيه بدات عمليات مغادره عدد
كبير من الرعايه تتحدثن عن الرعايه
الصينيين نتحدث عن الرحله الاولى كانت
علامتها 347 مواطن صيني ومساء امس هي
الرحله الثانيه على متنها
185 مواطن صيني ايضا تحدثنا عن الجاليه
الهنديه غادروا قرابه الالف هند
الصوت يتقطع ولكن هذه كانت صور خاصه لنا
من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده مع
مراسل عربيه سلطان السلمي حيث كان ينقل
لنا السفينه التي نزلت في القاعده وتقل
عدد كبير من الرعايه يتم اجلائهم في اطار
جهود السعوديه لاجلاء الرعايه من السودان
نتيجه الاشتباكات الخارجيه السعوديه قالت
منذ قليل ان عدد من تم اجلاؤهم من السودان
حتى الان تجاوز
5629 شخصا من 102 جنسيه
ومنهم
2009 239 مواطنا تم اجلائهم من السودان
وهذه صور للرعايه وهم ينزلون الان من على
هذه السفينه من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
في جده
ينضم اليها من جديد الزميل سلطان السلمي
سلطان مازلنا نتابع معك عمليه اجلاء
الرعايه ونزولهم عمليه الانزال من على هذه
السفينه سفينه الملك الرياض
بالفعل كما نشاهد عمليات الانزال تتم بشكل
سريع جدا ووفق بروتوكول معين ينطبق على
كافه السفن الاجلاء البحريه وحتى المدنيه
بدء بالحالات الطبيه ومن ثم النساء ومن ثم
كبار السن بعد ذلك بقيه الركاب كما نشاهد
في الاسفل يتم استقبالهم بالورد والحلوى
من ثم يتم تفويج او توجيه هؤلاء الرعايه
الى الحافلات الخاصه به متخصصات السلطات
السعوديه ومن ثم يتم انهاء اجراء الدخول
لهم الى او دخولهم الى الاراضي السعوديه
ومنحهم تاشيره استثنائيه
لمده شهر ايضا نشاهد هذا المشهد العسكري
السعوديين يقومون بمساعده كبار السن والكل
من يحتاج من لمساعدته في من النزول من
السفينه الى ارض القاعده يتم حملهما
ومساعدتهم وتوفير مقاعد او كراسي متحرك
لهؤلاء ايضا وجود مركبه الاسعاف التي
تتواجد منذ بدا عمليات الانزال حتى انتهاء
كافه هؤلاء الرعايه من النزول من متعه
سفينه جلاله الملك الرياض كما ذكرنا في
ظرف ساعه واحده يتم انهاء اجراءات الدخول
الخاصه بهم ومنحهم تاشيره لمده شهر وبعد
ذلك يتم تفويجهم وتسكنهم في اربعه فنادق
في جده فنادق ضخمه وفرات السلطات السعوديه
حتى يتسنى لهؤلاء الرعايه الاستراحه
وانهاء اجراءات السفر الخاصه بهم لمغادره
بلدانهم بعد الازمه الكبيره عاشوا
تفاصيلها هناك في السودان في ظل اشتباكات
المسلحه بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني وفي ظل كذلك انعدام القول قطاعات
الكهرباء وانعدام التمويل الغذائي وكذلك
المياه وعدم الاستقرار الامني هناك ايضا
المتوقع وصول عدد كبير من الرحلات الاجلاء
الخاصه بالسفن البحريه السعوديه يوم غدا
لا تزال الرحلات مستمره منذ بدء الازمه
ايضا من المتوقع
ظهر يوم غدا او عصر يوم غدا وصول رحله
مدنيه تجاريه سعوديه على متنها اعداد
يلامس للفين شخص بمختلف الجنسيات ايضا
ويتم وصولها الرعايه عبر هذه السفينه وسط
تامين من قبل القوات الخاصه التابعه
للبحريه السعوديه لتامين وصولهم بسلامه
الى من ميناء بورسودان الى قاعده
ممر شرفي
نعم كما نشاهد الان انتهت عمليات الانزال
يتم استقبالهم مبدئيا من قبل هؤلاء
القيادات الامنيه والمجندات السعوديات
وايضا يتم التاكد من صحتهم وسلامتهم بشكل
اولي ومن يحتاج الى علاج او حاله او رعايه
طبيه يتم اجلاءه عبر مركبات الاسعاف
المهيئه والمخصصه التي تم تجهيزها من وقت
مبكر ويتم مرورهم عبر ممر الشرفي حتى ان
يصلوا الى الحافلات المخصصه لهم في
الناحيه اخرى ممكن زميلنا عصام يعطينا
الصوره لهذه الحافلات الوقت مبكر لنقل
هؤلاء الرعايه الى مقرات السكن المخصصه
لهم وبعد ذلك يتم استقبالهم من قبل
السفراء والقنا بجده حتى يتسنى لهم العوده
في بلادهم في اقرب وقت ممكن بعد تقديم
كافه التسهيلات وتذليل كافه الصعوبات
لهؤلاء الرعايه والتعامل معهم بشكل انساني
اولا نعم اذا تابعنا مع الزميل سلطاننا
السلمي وصول سفينه سعوديه الى جده تحمل
220 من خمسه جنسيات تم اجلاؤهم من السودان
منهم 91 مواطنا امريكيا
تتابعون حضراتكم على الشاشه الان عمليات
الانزال الخاصه بهاؤلاء الرعايه ومنهم كما
ذكر الزميل سلطان كبار السن والاطفال وهي
ملاحظه لسلطان ان هذه السفينه تحمل عدد من
الاطفال
كانوا على متنها وهذه سيده كبيره في السن
ايضا تقوم القوات في قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه في جده بمساعدتها في عمليه
الانزال سلطان
الرعايه التي يمكن ان تتوفر لتلك الحالات
الخاصه لاننا نجد كبار سن وربما متعبين
بشده من الرحله مما شاهدوه من الشبكات هل
يتم توفير الخدمات الصحيه ايضا
نعم على متن هذه السفينه عياده طبيه تعمل
طوال الوقت كذلك توفير مناطق للاعاشه
هؤلاء الرعايه منذ انطلاق هذه السفينه
العسكريه التابع للقوات البحريه السعوديه
من ميناء بورت سودان وصولا الى قاعده
الملك فيصل اليوم اؤكد انه كان قد رافقنا
احد الرحلات الاجلاء البحريه من قاعده
الملك فيصل الى ميناء بورتسودان والعوده
الى مدينه جده رصدت صراحه حقيقه كثير من
المشاهد الانسانيه انه هؤلاء الضباط
والعسكر بمختلف الرتب العسكريه يتعاملون
بشكل انساني اولا لانه نعلم انه هؤلاء
الرعايه عاشوا معاناه كبيره في السودان في
ظل عدم استقرار الامن وفي ظل القطاعات
الكهرباء وشح المياه وكذلك قله التمويل
الغذائي لذلك يتم التعامل معهم بشكل
انساني ايضا وجود عدد كبير من
الموظفين الذين متخصصين في الرعايه
النفسيه للجلوس مع هؤلاء الرعايه وتقديم
الاستشارات النفسيه لهم طوال الرحله حتى
حتى يتسن لهم مغادره مدينه جده ايضا يتم
استقباله منى في القاعده عدد من السفراء
وممثلها هؤلاء الرعايه لانهاء اجراءاتهم
برفقه السلطات السعوديه ممثله في وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه او حتى كذلك برفقه
وزاره الخارجيه نعم اشكرك سلطان على كل
هذه المعلومات واعلى هذه الصور التي تم
نقلها الان على الهواء لحضراتكم لسفينه
نزلت في قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه وهي تقل
220 من الرعايه تم اجلائهم والرحلات
مستمره في اطار جهود المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لعمليه الاجلاء نذهب ايضا الى
بورسودان ومراس العربيه نزار البقدوي ايضا
لمتابعه حمله الاجلاء للرعايه ايضا في
بورسودان باعتباره ايضا محطه مهمه للاجلاء
ما هو الجديد نزار
نعم الجديد بان هذا اليوم هو اليوم الحادي
عشر لعمليه اجلاء رعايه دول الاجنبيه
وممثلي البعثات الدبلوماسيه وموظفي الامم
المتحده في هذه العمليه التي وصلت الى
يومها الحادي عشر خلال هذا اليوم اقلعت 70
رحله جويه من مطار بورسودان اضيفت اليها
رحلتان ظهر هذا اليوم اقلت مئتين 251 من
رعايه دوله الهند ليصبح عدد رعايه دوله
الهند الذين غادروا السودان عن طريق الجو
وعن طريق البحر يقدرون بثلاثه الاف
و330011 هندي وهنديه غادر السودان خلال
الايام الماضيه على سبيل التنسيق الذي
يجري الان للرحلات البحريه هنا من خلف
مباشره في ميناء بورسودان الحديث والتاكيد
عن اكثر من 25 رحله بحريه تمت خلال الايام
الماضيه اقلت اكثر من عشره الاف من رعايه
الدول الاجنبيه ودول عربيه ودول اوروبيه
غادروا ميناء بورسودان في طريقهم الى تلك
الدول المعلومات تتحدث عن وصول مرتقب ايضا
لسفينه بحريه السعوديه ستصل في غضون
الساعات المقبله ايضا المعلومات تتحدث عن
وصول سفينه امريكيه ايضا ستصل الى
الموانئ السودانيه خلال الساعات المقبله
التي تقل عددا من رعايا الدول الاجنبيه
والاوروبيه الذين وصلوا بالفعل هنا في
مدينه بورسودان هذه العمليه تمضي وتستمر
في يومها الحادي عشر
بتنسيق وباشراف كامل من قبل الجيش
السوداني
وبتنسيق ايضا من قبل قياده المنطقه
العسكريه هنا في ولايه البحر الاحمر التي
ترتب وتنسق هذا الامر مع هيئه الموانئ
البحريه ومع الشرطه السودانيه ومع مختلفه
الوحدات الاداريه التي تتكامل
وتتناغم في سياق انجاح هذه العمليه الكبرى
لجلاء رعايه دول العربيه والاوروبيه
والافريقيه من شرق السودان الى عدد من
الدول في المنطقه النزار هل تتم عمليه
الاجلاء بسهوله ام ان هناك صعوبات تواجه
الرعايه
للوصول الى اماكن يمكن ان تقل لهم الى
ما يتم او الوسائل التي يتم نقلها بهم
الصعوبه في بدايه هذا الامر كانت في طريقه
الخروج اثناء الاشتباكات والمواجهات
المسلحه في العاصمه الخرطوم وفي عدد من
المناطق فقد كانت هذه هي المعضله وهذه هي
الاشكاليه لما يرغب في مغادره العاصمه
الخرطوم ولكن بعد ان وصلوا مباشره الى
مدينه بورسودان اتم التنسيق مع البعثات
الدبلوماسيه تم التنسيق هنا مع اللجنه
اللجنه المعنيه بالاجلاء عبر مطار
بورسودان واللجنه المكلفه بتنسيق العمل
لاخراج الرعايه عبر مطار بورسودان الدولي
هاتان اللجنتان تعملان بتنسيق مشترك مع
البعثات
والمنسقيات الامميه هنا في مدينه بورسودان
والكثير من البعثات الدبلوماسيه رات وفضلت
ان تنسق بصوره كليه مع سفاره المملكه
العربيه السعوديه التي يبدو انها نقلت
جزءا كبيرا من مهامها الى مدينه بورسودان
ليس تسهل لها وليتسنى لها عمليه التنسيق
المباشر مع بقيه البعثات الدبلوماسيه التي
فضلت ان تعمل بتنسيق مع السفاره السعوديه
هنا في مدينه بورسودا لكن هنالك ثلاثه في
هذه العمليه حتى الان لم نستمع الى شكاوى
فقط الشكاوى تتعلق بالاكتضاف في اماكن
السكن تتعلق بالاجراءات المتعلقه بالتوقيت
الزماني لخروج البواخر ولخروج الطائرات من
مطار بورسودا عدا ذلك فان عمليه التنسيق
مستمره تبقى فقط معضله السوريين واليمنيين
والسودانيين العالقين من حمله الزيارات
ومن حمله الاقامات في عدد من الدول
العربيه فقد تبقى هذه المشكله ولكن
السلطات تقول بانها تعمل على تذليل كل
العقبات في اطار مشترك
هذه الازمه في السودان
بدات تعمل لعمليات الاجلاء كنا نستمع عن
مطار وادي سيدنا ولكن تم ايقاف العمل به
لايام ربما لتداعيات امنيه هل من اخبار
جديده حول هذا الامر
الان كل الرحلات الجويه او معظم الرحلات
الجويه تتم فقط في مطار بورسودان الدولي
كل الرحلات البحريه يبقى هنا في مطار هنا
هنا في ميناء بورت سودان او يمكن ان يكون
هنالك السبيل اخر للخروج عبر البحر من
ميناء السواكن وهو على مقربه من ميناء
بورسودان الطرق البريه الان السالكه نحو
منطقه القلابات الحدوديه على حدود السودان
مع اثيوبيا ايضا هنالك الطريقه البري
القاري الذي يربط بين السودان وجمهوريه
مصر العربيه في معبر ارجين واشكيت هذه هي
المنافذ لكن بورسودان تظل هي الوجهه
الجويه الوحيده بعد ان اغلق السودان مجاله
الجوي حتى اشعار اخر المطار حتى اشعار اخر
كما ذكرنا مطار بورسودان الميناء هو
الميناء الرئيس هنا المتاح حاليا لعمليه
اجلاء وخروج ومغادره رعايه الدول الذين
يرغب ون في مغادره السودان شكرا لزميلي
نزار من
مدينه مع حضراتكم عمليه الاجلاء التي تتم
من بورسودان وايضا تلك التي تتم ايضا من
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه هذه هي صور
تاتينا لعمليات الاجلاء المستمره التي
تساهم فيها المملكه العربيه السعوديه بشكل
كبير كبير لاجراء عدد كبير من الرعايه
الاجانب والسودانيين والحديث الان عن
محورين اساسيين للاجلاء مدينه بورسودان
وايضا قاعده الملك فيصل البحري
وفي اطار المطالبات السودانيه المدنيه
بالتفاوض دعا ياسر عرمان الناطق الرسمي
باسم قوى الحريه والتغيير في السودان الى
مظاهرات واسعه في المناطق غير المتاثره
بالصراع للدفع نحو التفاوض ووقف الحرب
واكد عرمان ان القرى والمدن التي لا
تشملها الحرب عليها ان تخرج بشكل واسع
للدفع بالتفاوض ووقف الحرب في البلاد
مؤكدا ان التفاوض سيقود البلاد الى
القضايا التي طرحت للمعالجه في الاتفاق
الايطاليه قائلا انه لابد من قوات مسلحه
مهنيه واحده وحكم مدني في السودان
قوات الدعم السريعه قالت في بيان لها منذ
ساعات انها اسقطت طائره من طراز تابعه
للجيش السوداني في الخرطوم وذكرت قوه
الدعم السريع انها تصدت لغارات عده شنها
الجيش السوداني صباح اليوم على مناطق
سكنيه بالخرطوم
ايضا الاشتباكات كانت قد تجددت وكانت لنا
صور حصريه في العربيه من محيط مطار
الخرطوم والقياده العامه حيث كانت هناك
مصادر صحفيه اشارت الى ان قوات الدعم
السريع حاولت الدخول الى مطار الخرطوم
وكان هناك رد من الطيران الحربي للجيش
السوداني بقصف هذه المحاولات
هذه هي وزاره التربيه والتوجيه بجنوب
دارفور تم الاعتداء عليها تماما وتم تدمير
كل المكاتب والاقسام الخاصه بالامتحانات
والخاصه بعمل التربيه والتوجيه هنا في
جنوب دارفور جنوب دارفور فيها تتم طباعه
جميع الامتحانات لاغليم دارفور تم تدمير
كامل لجميع ماكينات الطباعه في هذه
الوزاره كما تم نهب جميع الاجسام داخل هذه
الوزاره دمار كبير للبنيه التحتيه
والتربويه والتعليميه في جنوب دارفور
يحتاج العمل لاعاده هذا المكان الى وقت
طويل الخسائر لا حصر لها حتى الان تواصل
اللجان عملها لحصر الخسائر المتعلقه
بعمليات السلب والنهب داخل الوزارات
المختلفه ايضا تم نهب وزاره الماليه
بالولايه ومراكز تتبع للصحه مثل الصحه
الايجابيه ومركز التحصين ووزاره الصحه
وغيرها من المرافق الحكوميه الهامه في
جنوب دارفور
وفي ارقام الضحايا ومع استمرار المعارك في
السودان ارتفع عدد القتلى المدنيين جرائم
النزاع اذ اعلنت نقابه الاطباء السودانيه
عن ارتفاع حصيله للشبكات في السودان الى
447 قتيلا والفين مصاب
اعلنت ولايات البحر الاحمر وسينار
السودانيتان حاله الطوارئ لمده شهر حسب
وكاله انباء السودان وكان والي البحر
الاحمر المكلف فتح الله الحاج قد اصدر
امرا بحظر نقل السلع الاستراتيجيه خارج
حدود الولايه الا بموافقه الجهات المختصه
نشر حساب
المتخصص بالخرائط الحربيه خريطه لمنطقه
المعارك في الخرطوم اليوم الثلاثاء حيث
تظهر الخريطه سيطره واضحه للجيش في اغلب
مناطق العاصمه خصوصا من جهه الشمال وفي
وسط العاصمه الخرطوم تظهر الخريطه حاله
تجاذب بين الجيش والدعم السريع في وقت
تتوسع سيطره قوات الدعم بشكل كبير باتجاه
جنوب العاصمه كما تشاهدون معنا على الشاشه
اللون الاحمر يشير الى مناطق سيطره الجيش
السوداني اللون الاصفر يشير الى مناطق
سيطره قوات الدعم السريع
واللون الاخر يشير الى مناطق للنزاع ما
بين الطرفين انضموا الينا من الخرطوم
المحلل العسكري الفريق فتح الرحمن محي
الدين مرحبا بك سيد فتح لا اعلم اذا كنت
قد شاهدت هذه الخريطه هي الان على شاشه
العربيه
تشير الى ما يشبه التقاسم في مناطق النفوذ
ما بين قوات الدعم السريع وما بين الجيش
السوداني الجيش السوداني يسيطر في الشمال
شمال الخرطوم بينما قوات الدعم السريع في
الجنوب ما هو تعليقك
المشاهدين انا اعتقد انه يعني
الخريطه نوعا ما يعني قد تكون صحيحه ولكن
غير دقيقه يعني الجنوب الخرطوم نفسه مقسوم
الى جزء الشرقي وجزء غربي جزء غربي
بالكامل تحت سيطره المسلحه يعني اذا
تحدثنا من منطقه جبلوليا
واتجاه شمالا
منطقه ود العقليه الكلاكله
ولاب
وحتى شارع الغابه ولا حتى تقلي الى وسط
الخرطوم هذه كل المنطقه المسلحه
امتداد الديون
المسلحه صحيح هنالك وجود من ناحيه الشرقيه
من من
المناطق قد تكون الغريبه من من شارع بيت
ختيم من من
جنوب الى اتجاه سوبا هذه المناطق تكون
فيها عناصر للدعم السريع صحيحه وفيها ولكن
حتى هذه العناصر يعني هي موجوده بشكل
عصابات وليست
مواقع ثابته يتطهر في مكان لمده وجيزه ثم
تختفي ثم تصل في مكان اخر ثم طيب الخريطه
الان على الهواء والجميع يشاهدها سياده
الفريق هذه الخريطه اذا ما كانت دقيقه
وصحيحه كما ذكرت انت الان هذا يعني ان ليس
هناك طرف يسيطر على العاصمه الخرطوم نحن
نشاهد بيانات بين الحين والاخر لكلا
الطرفين كل منهما يدعي انه يسيطر على 90%
الخريطه تقول ان لا سيطره لاحد على
العاصمه الخرطوم وفقا لهذه الخريطه من كلا
الطرفين
يعني في وسط الخرطوم المناطق التي تتحصن
فيها عناصر الدعم السريع هي اما مناطق
سكنيه تتخذ من سكان دراما البشريه او
مرافق خدميه تحت لها عناصر الدعم السريع
والقوات المسلحه حريصه لا تدمر هذه
المناطق او او بعض المناطق الاستياديه
يعني وزاره الداخليه مثلا
انا اعتقد انه يعني سهله تطهيره ان اراد
ضربات المسلحه في خلال ساعه واحده يمكن ان
تفعل ذلك ولكنها تتعامل بشاشه النفس
الطويل
الجيش موجوده وجود فعله على الارض وكل من
يتحرك يجد عناصر الاوقات المسلحه امامهم
لكن مناطق الدعم السريعه كما ذكرت لقيتها
والمجموعات تعمل بنفس نظام حرب العصابات
يعني ليس لها مغارات ثابته ليس لهم معسكر
واحدا ينامون فيه ليس لهم مكان واحدا
بخلافه التي يحتلوها
سواء للجيش السوداني او لقوات الدعم
السريع هذا هذا ما تشرحه انت الان على
الهواء لهذه الخريطه
اللعبه تمام اقول لك اللغات المسلحه ان
اراده الحزم العسكري لحسمت هذا الموضوع
موقوف ولكن هي تخشى من الخسائر المدنيه
غير المبرره وتخشع من تدمير البنيه
التحتيه اكثر مما يجب
يتحصل فيها عناصر الدعم السريع وبالتالي
الرواه المسلحه تظل تتعامل مع هذه مع هذه
المجموعات لسياسه النفس الطويل
ان يدخل معهم في تفاوض في الخروج من
المرافق الخدميه حتى تتمكن الجهات المعنيه
اعاده الخدمات للمواطن وتسهيل حياه
المواطن نقطه مهمه جلوس الطرفين معا هذه
لاول مره يتم الحديث عن هذا الامر هل هو
تطبيقا لمبادره جنوب السودان بالفعل
سيلتقم ممثلين عن البرهان وممثلين عن
حميدتي خلال الايام القليله القادمه
انا اعتقد انه مبادره جنوب السوداني جاءت
متاخره يعني سبقت جنوب السودان المبادله
الامريكيه السعوديه وهي التي الان جاري
ترتيب النواحي اللوجستيه لنقل ممثل اللغات
المسلحه ممثل الدعم السريع الى جده لتنفيذ
هذا الاتفاق الذي يفضي الى اخراج عناصر
الدعم السريعه من وسط الاحياء السكنيه ومن
وسط المرافق
نحن نبحث عن معلومات حول هذا الامر اللقاء
سيكون في جده
نعم سيكون في جده وجاري الترتيبات الان
النرجسيه لنقل الممثلين الى جده لكي يتم
كما ذكرت لك تحسين تحسين الوضع الانساني
والاستفاده من الهدن التي كل مره تعلن ولم
يستفيد منها المواطنين معلومات
لمصادر عسكريه يشير الان الى انه تم
الاتفاق بالفعل على لقاء ممثلين من
البرهان ومن حميتي يلتقون في جده السعوديه
حيث بدء التفاوض حول مساله ترتيبات وقف
اطلاق النار شكرت المديره التنفيذيه
لبرنامج الغذاء العالمي سيدني ماكينه
سعوديه على مساعدتها في اجراء فريق برنامج
الغذاء العالمي من السودان ايضا عبرت
ماكين عن امتنان برنامج الامم المتحده
للاغذيه لجهود الخارجيه السعوديه وسفاره
الرياض في الخرطوم على جهودهم في المساعده
باجلاء من يرغب بالخروج من السودان جرى
الاشتباكات
ايضا قالت المتحدثه باسم مكتب المفوض
السامي للعمم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
اولغا ان اكثر من 100 الف لاجئ عبروا من
السودان الى الدول المجاوره هربا من
الصراع بينما نزح مئات الالاف بسبب العنف
داخل البلاد
هم من بين اولئك الذين الى البلدان
المجاوره ويشمل هذا الرقم ايضا اللاجئين
في جنوب السودان المفوضيه الساميه للامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين حددت الى جانب
الحكومات والشركاء رقم تخطيط اولي لاكثر
من 800
وعائد قد يفرون من السودان الى البلدان
المجاوره
قال المتحدث باسم المنظمه الدوليه للهجره
ان عدد النازحين ارتفع بوتيره سريعه في
الاسبوعين الماضيين بسبب القتال المتواصل
بين المكونين العسكريين
نزح ما لا يقل عن
334 الف شخص داخليا نتيجه الصراع الحاصل
وفقا لتقرير شبكه قياس تتبع النزوح
التابعه للمنظمه الدوليه للهجره ارتفع عدد
النازحين خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين نتيجه
تواصل الصراع في السودان جميع حالات
النزوح مرتبطه بالظروف الصعبه والازمات
التي زادت منذ عام 2022
هذا وكشف المدير الاقليمي للاعلام في
يونيسيفا لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا عمار عمار العربيه كشف عن خساره
اكثر من مليون لقاح ضد شلل الاطفال
والعديد من الادويه اثر عمليه النهب من
مخازن المنظمه في السودان مؤكدا على
انقطاع العلاج لاكثر من 50 الف طفل يعاني
من سوء التغذيه الحد هي 50,000 يعني
من سوء التغذيه الحاد الوخيم انقطعت عنهم
العلاج في مراكز او الرعايه المنقذه
للحياه في المراكز التغذيه التابعه التي
تدعمها في خاصه في مناطق الاشتباكات مواد
المنقده للحياه فقدت
اكثر من مليون لقاح
للاطفال في في في بعض المناطق التي نعمل
بها وفي دارفور ايضا بسبب الذي تعرضت اليه
يعني مخازنه ومخازن شركاء ايضا يجب ان يتم
تصبيرها بشكل كامل ويج ب ان تكون مكرونه
ايضا بضمانات امنيه
للمنظمات الانسانيه العامله على ارض
الميدان فهذول الشرطين لحتى تقدر اليونسيف
منظمات انسانيه اخرى ان تقوم بشكل فعال
وشامل وكامل للاستجابه للاحتياجات
الانسانيه الهائله على ارض على ارض
الميدان
وفي متابعه لتطورات الاوضاع الصحيه قلا
المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه السودانيه محمد
ابراهيم عبد الرحمن ان تسعه وثلاثين
مستشفى خرجت عن الخدمه منذ بدء الاشتباكات
مؤكدا العربيه ان قوات الدعم الساريه حولت
بعض المستشفيات الثقنه عسكريه عبد الرحمن
دعا الى فتح ممرات انسانيه لاغاثه الضحايا
التي توقفت على الخدمه منذ صباح يوم 15
وحتى اليوم هي 39 مستشفى هذه المستشفيات
هي في مناطق الاشتباكات حتى تاريخ اليوم
مناطق غير امنه هي المستشفيات التي متاخمه
لمناطق الاشتباك شارع القصر وشارع
المطار والقياده والاذاعه ومركز
ومركز البحري
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات